hey everybody it's the movie
retrospective right before halloween
so you knew that we had to do
the rocky horror picture show
i'm actually kind of happy that it well
i put it in the poll because i was like
well duh it's halloween so of course
um but then i was afraid that it
wouldn't win but it won like
overwhelmingly so i'm good i'm like good
because that was the one i wanted to do
anyway hardly we hadn't done this one i
yeah yeah i find it really hard to
believe too well the thing about rocky
horror picture show it's almost kind of
like i feel like it's one of those
movies that is like transcended movie
dumb it's not even really a movie
anymore it's like a cultural phenomenon
it's an event i mean the [ __ ] has been
running
continuously since 1975.
i don't believe it's ever been out of
theaters
since 1975
and i don't think there's any other
single movie in history that can say
that and i had never seen it you had
never seen it no i saw like certain
numbers out of it like certain musical
numbers but i hadn't seen the whole
thing but until just until we watched it
other day you had never sat and watched
the whole thing holy crap i've never
seen it that's amazing i just had no
interest that's amazing and it was
around when i was a little kid
well yeah like i said
yeah like i said it's been around since
people dressed that way
i didn't know you know what it was why
is he pointing that pitchfork at that
man
what oh yeah the ray gun was in front of
the front oh okay
yeah okay i was like pitchfork there's a
pitchfork
i just put a handle on it well yeah it's
like a laser gun yeah i just didn't know
what you're talking about yeah that's
great
i was i think i was actually kind of
lucky enough that when i was in high
school in the late 1980s
um i had never seen it either
until then
uh but i had a cousin my cousin greg who
was a year or two older than me and he
was really into it and he would go every
week because even in the rednecky
town of daytona beach where we grew up
there was one theater that played it
every saturday night
and so he was kind of like a regular
that went and he's like oh my god i
can't believe you're into all this goth
[ __ ] and you've never
seen it so he took me to it one night
and then um i don't know if you know but
when you go to the theaters uh to see it
if you've never seen it before they
always ask and of course if a friend
takes you it'd be like virgin virgin
like right here so of course they stand
you up and humiliate you and stuff so
yeah i had all of that done to me and
stuff as well so i think it's like it's
good because i saw it the first time the
way you know ideally you're supposed to
see it in the theater with a cast with a
you know participating
audience like with a whole bunch of
people that brought all the props and
like some people were dressed up and
like i said we had a live cast as well
and honestly one a girl that went to
high school with me she wasn't i didn't
know her but she was like friend of a
friend type i think her name was what
was her name tara theresa something like
that and uh she was actually the regular
um magenta in the cast and she looked a
lot like her she looked a lot like
patricia quinn and they had a really
good i remember they had a really good
um
frank infertor too but he wasn't there
all the time like they had like two or
three different ones that would come in
depending on who was available but for a
long time during my high school years
and a couple years after i graduated um
me and a bunch of my friends would go
like every saturday night if we didn't
have anything else going on and i think
even like when we went to prom like our
senior prom
and we were there for like an hour or
two we're like this shit's boring let's
go to rocky horror so we ended up going
to rocky horror like in our prom outfits
which i thought was kind of funny
because we got like [ __ ] bored at the
[ __ ] [ __ ] the um it was better
quality than i had anticipated really
yeah i thought it was going to be like
lower budget
no it's not it's
it's it's really just a musical like any
other musical from the period i didn't
really think there's i don't have really
kind of the emotional connection to it
it's just
it's it's a musical
uh the it's basically 1950s horror is
what what the yeah horror sci-fi stuff
yeah but it also has like a um
a uh like a not prog rock what do you
call that [ __ ] glamorous glam rock it's
like it's like a glam rock motif and
some kind of 50s rock and roll yeah and
50s mixed in with it it's uh kind of
reminded me of a of um
phantom of the paradise well phantom of
the paradise uh the movie came out in
1974 and the movie rocky horror picture
show came out in 1975 however
uh rocky horror show the stage musical
came out in 1973.
so phantom of the paradise i don't know
if they were working on at the same time
um because fan of the of the paradise
does definitely seem like it took some
stuff from rocky horror like the stage
musical yeah so it's possible that it
could have because it does have some of
the same aspects totally honest i
probably would take a fan of the
paradise overall see i know i like
paradise i like the story now
i could see that you know the reason why
this one's stuck is because i
it has a quite a gender bending kind of
[ __ ] humor to it you know what i mean
it's
and it's because these aliens are
transsexuals from transylvania or some
[ __ ] like that yeah
and uh it is it is funny
um
but
it's just i don't know the performances
were good the music was pretty good most
most of the numbers were good the story
was
ludicrous you know which is supposed to
be and it kind of rips off frankenstein
and dracula and everything else it's
just ripping off everything
50s or 2 you know it's good it's just
i think i think phantom of the paradise
is a little bit of quality i i thought
you know see i don't i like phantom of
the paradise but i think rocky horror is
way better and honestly i guess it's
because like i said i you know i started
going to rocky who are like the theater
uh production and it's still fun to like
watch um you know at home and i hadn't
done that for a long time so i watched
it on hulu like a couple nights ago and
i was like man i forgot like how good
because i used to have the soundtrack
and all that other kind of stuff
it is like way more fun to see with like
audience participation but to be honest
i think what ended up happening is
because i saw it so many times
in the theater and if you've never been
to see it like in the theater you know
everybody's like yelling lines back at
the screen and then there's like a you
know there's like a um
you know you get everybody gets up and
does the dances and [ __ ] like that
there's all this kind of script that you
follow and then there's like kind of a
cast in front of the screen too like
acting the [ __ ] out and so there's a lot
of other chaos and so i kind of feel
like you get so into that that you sort
of like lose track of what's going on in
the movie so it wasn't until later on
like when i saw the movie like when i
bought it on dvd or whatever
and was able to watch it at home without
all the other stuff going on that
actually i started to appreciate all the
kind of littler stuff
about
the story and about like and even when i
was watching it recently like there's
like just little funny [ __ ] in there
that i never really
saw like the first several times i
watched it because there was so much
other stuff going on you know what i'm
saying i did like it though you know and
i i think the
i think one of the best part about it is
it has a really strong sense of humor
and i think a lot of the humor in some
ways
was frozen in time and in a certain way
i don't know if it translates today
exactly the way it was back then
in the era of glam rock
and even in the in the era of like early
heavy metal when you know and [ __ ]
motley crew and [ __ ] not really that
wasn't early la early l.a medal you know
like motley crue showed up there was
kind of a those dudes were wearing their
girlfriend's clothes it was it was
it did kind of have a gender bending
[ __ ] look to it this goes all the way
back to like [ __ ] you know new york
dolls and [ __ ]
thinking even like to a certain expect
you know david bowie and everything
[ __ ] iggy pop and and all these guys
looking
but those dad guys were kind of trolling
you know with this rocky horror picture
show
seemed to be trolling them to take it
even to the next step where they were
just going it's straight up [ __ ] you
know that's
and it was kind of funny you know
but um
that's how i interpreted the humor they
were just it'd be like
me it was it's a rock opera that's what
it is well imagine if you were doing a
gothic opera kind of like the repo man
did but then you take it even to the
next level where it's kind of trolling
itself where it's kind of a self-aware
that's that's that's what the tone
seemed like to me
you know and then and they're kinda it's
trolling
it was trolling um
uh rock music of the time and also troll
in the mainstream too because
a lot of people were still around it
from the 1950s and they were probably
pretty [ __ ] stuffy to be around so it
was kind of trolling that but it was
also
kind of homaging the horror of the 1950s
which was cheesy but fun you know well
and i really liked and i think that if
you're really into
50s b horror movies and sci-fi movies as
richard o'brien who you know was the
creator of this originally as he was
there's a lot of really cool kind of
like little in jokes i particularly like
the addition of the criminologist who
comes in and he's very straight faced
and he's telling you what's going on
because it reminds me of like the dude
from uh i think the dude from mole
people and it's like there were so many
like 50s horror movies that had that
aspect where they would have a very
serious like professional turns out he's
wearing pantyhose
yeah well i mean you know he's getting
up doing like [ __ ] [ __ ] like that but
but i really like and then and you know
them kind of like trolling the squares
and everything yeah yeah but yeah so
richard o'brien
uh who if you don't know he plays he
played riff raff in the movie but he was
the one that wrote uh all the music and
the lyrics he sings some of the songs he
sings the opening song uh double feature
uh you know science fiction double
feature he sings that and a couple of
other ones in there and so he was um
he's english but i think he lived in new
zealand for a really long time and he
was kind of doing like a lot of theater
stuff i think he was in like jesus
christ superstar and [ __ ] like that like
in london back in the early 70s and i
guess he got the idea for rocky horror
because like i said he was really into
like you said the sort of gender bending
glam rock type of thing because he was
he considered himself i guess
transgender or third gender or something
like that he's like i don't really
identify with binary well yeah he's like
i don't really identify with either one
of them it's you know what i mean i'm
kind of in the middle somewhere yeah so
uh glam rock was kind of good uh you
know for those kind of people it kind of
gave them something to belong to he was
also really into
50 sci-fi 50s horror um you know [ __ ]
going back even horror going back to the
30s and he was also really into like 50s
rock and roll so he wanted to
do a musical
that would incorporate all of those
things like he's like maybe like
frankenstein like a mad scientist but
with like transgender elements and this
kind of like crazy kind of [ __ ] and so
he wrote it like over a winter or
something and he knew this dude who was
like an australian guy jim sharman
who
uh richard o'brien had met when they
were working on jesus christ superstar
and jim sharma was like oh yeah we'll
totally do that so they started out like
in this really really small theater in
london
but it was so successful
that it eventually ended up going bigger
and bigger bigger theaters and it ended
up in the west end so it was this big
like cultural phenomenon so then jim
sharman was like well okay well maybe we
can do like a movie version of this and
then they ended up doing it in the u.s
and most of the cast like tim curry as
frank infertile who obviously is like
jesus is the best [ __ ] thing about
this movie i could watch him all day
long because he is just like he just
[ __ ] leans right into it man he's
just he looks like he's having a [ __ ]
fantastic time yeah and uh but he was
actually in most of the london stage
plays so they wanted most of the
original cast uh little nell who played
colombia
patricia quinn he played magenta you
know obviously richard o'brien he played
riff raff uh that those were all like
original uh they were all original stage
cast so they wanted them to be in the
movie but i don't know like who in the
original stage musicals in
in the uk i don't know who played brad
and janet but when they made the
uh you know the movie they wanted
american actors obviously so they got
barry boswick and susan sarandon to be
in it now interestingly when this movie
came out
um as you might imagine it was kind of
not real success but it was successful
in l.a
like people like dug it there yeah
but and in some places in new york but
other than that it was just kind of like
you know it really didn't find much of
an audience they wouldn't understood
this but what ended up happening though
was that slowly what they started to do
because
there had been some success with some
other midnight movies like reefer
madness was kind of one popular one and
some john waters movies like pink
flamingos and stuff like they'd started
showing them at midnight and like
weirdos would come up and see them so
then like they kind of go to some fox
executive and they're like why don't we
do like a midnight movie [ __ ] with this
and see how that goes and they're like
all right we'll see how that flies and
they started doing it and then they
noticed that
in
like it started out in big cities like i
said in new york l.a stuff like that but
then they still slowly noticed that it
was like doing it around the country
where the same people would turn up to
see the movie like every weekend it
became a thing and then they were
starting to
kind of come up with their own you know
they're doing like a call and response
type of thing where they're coming up
with their own uh mst lines yeah they're
responding to the movie yeah and so in
the movie yeah it's weird though because
like when i used to go back in high
school like i said in the late 80s early
90s and i think this is true across
you know i think scripts are different
like no matter what uh theater you go to
but
you gotta like adhere to the script you
can't just like fly off and like make up
your own [ __ ] well you can but it has to
be like super super funny normally
there's a script and you have to adhere
to it because otherwise you're not like
not part of the club you know what i
mean because you don't know
that particular you know city's script
but everything kind of has its own thing
and i think there are some lines that
are sort of like universal and i think
since um
because i remember there had been like
some bootleg records and stuff like that
of the soundtrack you know of the movie
with all the lines in it and now like
now we have the internet so there's
scripts all over the place yeah
that would be successful you know
because you'd have something for the for
the [ __ ] weirdos to go do it was
you know like every weekend kind of like
a if you didn't have a goth club yeah
and it's predated all that [ __ ] then you
could go see this [ __ ] flick and it
was like group participation and have a
good time you know they're probably
getting high in there they're hooking up
yeah and uh it's kind of like an mst
watching an episode of mst but you're
the ones that [ __ ] that are making
[ __ ] stuff up so i could i can see
and you know you this is probably
happening in places that didn't really
have a good club scene or maybe a lot of
kids are [ __ ] too young to get into
the club so you could do that but i'm
thinking of us all ages though
well yeah was this our i mean i guess it
probably was
but so i guess if you're under 17 you
couldn't get in there but i kind of feel
like it would have been that would have
been rude but i mean yeah they would you
would just snuck in because i'm pretty
sure i went in there before i was 17.
they wouldn't care i don't think they
didn't enforce that [ __ ] when i was
a kid
but yeah so yeah this is definitely you
can see but it's interesting because
this seems to have happened i mean it
did have a little bit of marketing um
you know they kind of marketed it uh you
know at first they tried to do uh they
actually tried to do a double feature
with um you know phantom of the paradise
for a little while which
didn't yeah because they are very
similar themed type of movies i could
see this would be better for the group
participation versus the [ __ ]
paradise though phantom of the paradise
is jam-packed full of bunch of stuff and
it's more like something you just listen
to yeah like repo man or something you
mean we play the genetic opera yeah i
was going to correct you on that before
because i think you said repo man like
that's a totally different movie yeah
opera yeah or um
a little shop of [ __ ] you know
yeah the thing about um the thing about
rocky horror picture show is that
it's very aware of what it is i mean
like i said richard o'brien was really
really into
50s schlocky b movies and horror movies
and he was really into like you know old
horror like classic horror and he was
trying to do like very deliberately
trying to do a parody of that
um but also like a loving homage to it
so that's why you know that's why
there's certain things in there and like
even like the opening song references
like a bajillion different like old
sci-fi movies like tarantula and the day
the earth stood still and you know he
says like all the you know the actors
that are in it everything like that
because he was like really really into
that
say what the tim curry pulls that
[ __ ] roll off he's like that's god
best that's the best transsexual
impersonator i've ever seen i have nev
honestly i had forgotten because i've
like i said i've seen this movie a
zillion times i have like the the poster
like another set of jaws poster with the
lips on it i have that it's like so i've
seen it a million times at the
soundtrack i know all the songs by heart
um but i hadn't seen it in a few years
like i hadn't actually sat and watched
it
and when we watched it it's actually i
think it's on disney plus because disney
took over the company you know that
owned it originally and they allowed it
to continue in theaters because it still
plays in theaters uh to this day and
people still go see it every weekend um
but i saw it on hulu they put it up
there for hulu ween
which they do every year but uh but i
hadn't sat and watched it for probably
like five or six years at this point and
i had forgotten i was like goddamn one i
forgot how good tim curry was in this i
mean he's just like
he's the best part about the movie i
mean well yeah i mean easily but i also
forgot how good the [ __ ] songs were
like how catchy the songs were oh shows
up yeah yeah eddie yeah he does a good
number
everybody's good in it everybody's good
and like i said because because i told
you before i didn't realize that you had
never seen the movie i never seen it
when we were watching it that's like
that blows my mind i thought everybody
had seen it it didn't happen there was a
[ __ ] uh a kind of like a tone shift
it's it starts off kind of funny and and
positive
it starts to go kind of negative towards
the end or where it's a little bit of a
downer
but that's just the part of the story
that's just the way the story goes and
and the music kind of changes a little
bit at least it did for me that was my
first impression of it
well it started to become a little bit
of like like a little bit downbeat you
know what i mean because well it kind of
goes
into horror territory like in a kind of
hardcore horror territory because when
it starts out
it's kind of from brad and janet's point
of view and there's sort of these
wide-eyed naive virginal
squares oh that's just [ __ ] funny
because frank and further [ __ ] [ __ ]
them both
behind each other's back
and then she found out i never would
have never never
it's funny man because he's they're
aliens you know i mean like [ __ ]
aliens from
transylvania
god they're like these gothic well the
planet is called transsexual
the galaxy is called transylvania okay
the galaxy transformation yeah
get it right
[Laughter]
it's just it's nonsense it's just funny
[ __ ] yeah well that's what i mean but it
was very self-aware nonsense and like i
said if you're real into
you know be horror and stuff like that
it's like there's a lot of really funny
[ __ ] in there and honestly some of this
stuff that i had forgotten about i mean
other than like i said tim curry is
[ __ ] he's great in everything i love
tim curry but
this is just you can tell that he is
just having a [ __ ] blast in this role
and like i said he'd played it many
times before because he played it on the
stage so you can tell that he's very
comfortable yeah yeah okay yeah you can
tell he knows what he's doing he [ __ ]
hams that [ __ ] up and then at the end
the alien cops show up the alien
transsexual cops show up that was
[ __ ] good too
well they weren't cops it was riffraff
and magenta yeah i know but they were
like in their cop uniforms that's how i
[ __ ] interpreted it well that was
that was their nate i think that was
just their native that's what they would
wear like if they weren't on earth the
way what okay what way i interpreted it
is that they were kind of like
undercover cops and that now they're
feeling right america got arrested and
[ __ ] you know what i mean oh it might
have been that's how i that's how i end
we'll see because i don't know i don't
take him back to his [ __ ] home world
and [ __ ] but then but then turns out now
he's gonna kill him yeah well yeah they
wanted to kill him well because what had
ended up happening was that essentially
i don't think they spell this out in the
movie but it's implied that however long
they've been on earth
um you know dr frank has been
like these well they're well
he's like he made riffraff and magenta
into servants they were servants and he
was like mean to them okay because he
was just kind of he was always kind of
like
uh you know he made riff-raff call him
master and he was like whipping him and
stuff he was like an igor type character
yeah so after a while like when you know
when frank was kind of distracted or
weakened or whatever
him and magenta who were brother and
sister by the way um
they decided they were gonna like drop
their nuts and like take back over and
get rid of him and then go back to
because i guess he made them come to
earth like maybe i'm thinking too much
about it i think he made them come to
earth like without their like they
didn't want to
in my limited [ __ ] understanding of
the movie you've seen it watch the first
time i thought that somehow they were
kind of like undercover cops or they had
become alien cops oh see that would be
funny that they were gonna i never
thought bringing them to justice that's
how because they showed up in those new
outfits i thought they were uniforms
that's how i see i thought they were
uniforms too but i thought they were
just saying it's like [ __ ] this earth
[ __ ] this is our like our native garb
from their planet
um you know because i i got the
impression that frank had brought them
there like against their will and was
like making him making them be his
servants yeah because that's what he
that's what he treated them like now
colombia he makes a muscle man that's
the best part of it yeah and gives him a
bunch of weight says the president
that song i can make i can make you a
man is like so [ __ ] funny every
single song of this is so [ __ ] good
like all the lyrics are funny it's like
all the like i said if you know all the
lyrics and stuff like the lyrics are
[ __ ] hilarious and richard richard
o'brien wrote all those but it's like
but yeah so
but columbia is not an alien though i
think she's just um because even at the
beginning when they do like they're
introducing everybody that she's just a
groupie
so i think she was just like a person
that fell in love with frank
and he kind of like let her hang around
the castle
and then and then but then he fell in
love with eddie he was meatloaf's
character and then eddie
and colombia kind of fell in love and
then frank decided he didn't want eddie
around anymore so he was going to make
rocky the muscle man
so it's a it's like i said it seems like
it's just really weird coming at it
where
you know having seen it so many times i
probably saw it like 200 times
in a theater situation
uh you know with everybody yelling out
the their lines and everything and so in
that situation everybody's throwing
toast and rice and [ __ ] like that the
skin hot dogs and whatever at the screen
um which they used to do
i know i always used to feel bad for
like the theater they're like god damn
it the [ __ ] rocky horror people i
think after a while
um
because at first they'd let you like
bring anything right but then after a
while they're like okay well you can
bring you know xy you can bring
newspaper you can bring rice you can be
but enough with the toast and the hot
dogs and that kind of like we don't want
to clean up like rotten food and [ __ ]
but it's like so could we they can you
can bring playing cards and stuff like
that but there was some things that they
most theaters wouldn't allow you to
bring just because it was gross and
unsanitary but uh for a while in the 70s
i've i felt bad for like the people that
worked in the theaters back then because
they probably had to clean up all kind
of terrible things but um
but yeah so
seeing it so many times in that
environment
i don't think
i never it's weird i never really paid
attention to the story because i was
kind of like into the songs and like
remembering all the lines and everything
but
when i was watching it again recently i
was kind of like this is actually a
pretty good story there's like a lot
going on in there that i didn't pick up
on the first because i wasn't like
really listening to everybody's dialogue
but there is actually a story going on
in there and like i said it's actually
like a much smarter story than i think i
gave the movie credit for for a long
time just because i was just kind of
into the songs and following along and
having a good time and checking
everybody's costumes and stuff like that
but i was like it does actually have
a really good story and honestly even
though you say like the end is a downer
i really really like that whole
that whole end sequence the floor show
sequence with it starts out with um you
know with rose tint my world and then
they go into and then the song is like
get sadder and sadder uh and then
finally you know frank gets killed
spoiler alert um you know
and then the movie and then the whole
and then the whole um castle like takes
off and like goes back to the planet so
i guess they brought the whole castle
link to the [ __ ] it's just ridiculous
but like i said but it's ridiculous on
purpose yeah and i think that
because of that it's interesting that
phantom of the paradise which like i
said probably came out like a year or
two before this although like i said the
stage show
for this had come out prior to phantom
of the paradise uh so
rocky horror show the stage musical was
already a little bit of a phenomenon
before the movie came out not so much in
the u.s but i guess in the uk
but when the movie came out here it's
like it didn't do all that well except
in the big cities and everything but
then
it really seemed to like strike a chord
in the way that phantom of the paradise
really didn't and i'm not sure because
like i said they're very similar and i
know you like phantom of the paradise
better i honestly think rocky horror is
a lot better i love phantom of the
paradise don't say that i don't like
think i'm saying that but
i i mean i think rocky horror i thought
the songs are more memorable i think i
just like the tone of it better it's a
lot more fun it's a lot more
tongue-in-cheek
it's a lot more
self-aware
maybe because it's more
i don't know i mean
fan of the paradise is nowhere near as
over the top as rocky or rocky horror is
absurd yeah and like i said it's like
it's like fun though and even there's
like really over-the-top horror elements
like when eddie gets killed like frank
kills eddie with a pickaxe and then they
eat him yeah like they kind of pull he
pulls the the thing off the table and
like there's a coffin under there he's
all cut up
and it's like i love that dinner scene
too like where they're eating the
they're eating the the meat which just
kind of looks like a big whatever and
he's cutting it with that uh
one of those hamilton beach like
automatic like carving knives or
whatever which always cracks me up for
some reason and uh so they're eating and
then you know the doctor guy was like dr
scott he's like
i came here to talk to you about eddie
and frank's chewing he's like that's a
little bit of a tender subject and then
they all realize at the same time that
they're all eating him and then they're
just like oh
and it's just like it's just little
moments like that like that whole dinner
scene where
where uh brad is like looking in the
there all the cups are mismatched and
he's like looking in the mug and he's
like wiping it all off like it's gross
and just like little things like that
where you know the one part where riff
raff and magenta are like laughing in
each other's faces like over the chair
like
and then he goes shut up
it's just like [ __ ] like that i don't
know just like little things like that
crack me up more than anything and i
think i appreciate them more now than i
did when i first saw it because all
these like little details i think i
missed even though i'd seen it like a
zillion times yeah i can't comment on
the live [ __ ] [ __ ] where you throwing
[ __ ] i just i've never been to it oh it
was super fun i used to go every weekend
for years and years i'm just i'm just uh
giving my uh a review of it based on the
movie that we saw
and just based on the movie that i saw
it's a good move it's a good musical
it's um
it's very rock opera
uh the acting's real good the dancing's
really good it's got its [ __ ]
outrageous sense of humor to it
it's uh it it's it's good i see why pete
why a a
kind of like a culture growing up
um if you like
rocky horror and haven't seen family
paradise see that yeah very similar
you'll like that too it's a fan of the
opera
style
story about rock stars it's good it's
good um it doesn't
uh it's not as um i guess you could say
it's not it doesn't have kind of like a
a gendered theme like a gender bending
thing it doesn't really have that no
more than normal rock music had yeah
because it was like that um
uh
i'd put them on par with one another
actually on par
but the music wise the songs i liked the
phantom of the paradise better it was
a little more sophisticated music in
terms of just like musically a little
more sophisticated it almost sounded
like the greatest hits that you've heard
before but it wasn't
it was just [ __ ] they pulled out of
their ass
i'm a fan of the paradigm yeah although
i i'm although i'm sitting here right
now and i'm trying to think of like some
of the songs from fan of the paradise
and i can only think of one i can't
think of the other ones but maybe like i
said that's probably because i've seen
rocky or a zillion times yeah i've seen
i've only seen phantom of the paradise
like once
yeah i can't i couldn't repeat any of
those songs but every time i heard every
time i heard him i was like oh okay yeah
there that's a take off on a bowie song
or like okay yeah that's a take off on a
damn
um you know
it just sounded everything sounded
familiar
and and um
found the paradise interestingly too
then now that you bring up david bowie
um sue blaine uh who did the costumes
for this
and whoever i can't remember who it was
that did the makeup for the movie
because i think they you know changed up
the makeup for the movie from the stage
play a little bit but whoever did the
makeup for the rocky horror picture show
movie was uh had worked with david bowie
as well as mick jagger so they got like
rockstar people and sue blaine who did
the costumes
um
actually
she kind of thinks i don't yeah and
maybe this is the case is that the whole
like torn fishnet thing like the the
makeup the hair
and stuff like that um she kind of
credited that with maybe
uh being influential on the punk scene
like later on which i can totally see
cause she said she didn't really
look into a lot of um
she just kind of like winged it when she
was making the costumes for this
um and didn't really look into a lot of
other things that were going on um so
she claims that
you know the that some of the stuff that
shows up in rocky horror was influential
on the punk so she was kind of like
really influential
in punk fashion yeah i mean big time
and the thing about it that's goth yeah
and yeah and like you said i kind of
feel like
even i know that in the early 70s yeah
pokey's been she's loving all the treats
she's being bad she wants us to open
those treats she can smell them yeah
she's new flavor she's like i've never
had that flavor it's the tasty human
flavor yeah that's a halloween flavor
so you could smell right this she was
she wants to eat a human i'm gonna give
it to you she wants to eat it she's
looking at me i'm gonna give it to
you yeah i just it's just kind of like i
know that there was a lot of this sort
of stuff going on in the early 70s
but
watching it and honestly i'm kind of
like watching it again now in 2021 i'm
kind of like amazed that they got away
with what they got away with in this
movie i mean there's a lot of [ __ ] that
i was like laughing my ass off at like
the one scene where
um you know i love the two like doubling
scenes where frank goes in there and
like seduces janet first
and then goes and seduces brad like with
pretty much the same lines and he's just
kind of like okay whatever and they just
kind of do it it's it's kind of in
silhouette but it's like he totally
looks like he's like giving him a bj and
it's like it's really really funny and
then like they show the kind of thing
afterward where brad's like sitting
there smoking and
frank's like laying back there in bed
all looking satisfied [ __ ] and it's just
like funny and it's like funny to me
that that they got away with that like
in 1975 i guess well in the 70s he got
away with a lot of [ __ ] that's what i'm
saying it was there was [ __ ] that they
were doing back then that you could have
never
gotten away with from that damn brook
shield stuff and [ __ ] what was that
pretty baby well yeah that underage
underrated stuff was going on yeah but
i'm talking about just yeah she's being
she's being okay look i'm gonna give it
to you
we have to give her the treats because
otherwise your treats are huge she's
gonna we're not paying attention to her
so she's like give her one or something
no i didn't give her how does she know
she can she can smell it right through
there she smells through the yeah okay
you're gonna smell right there yeah
tasty human flavor okay
look at her look at what she said she's
gone yeah i want some whether she's with
her big guys
come here let me give you some
take those
okay
all right
but yeah it's like it's just like i said
it's kind of blowing my mind that that
you had never seen this whole entire
movie because i thought because you know
you were kind of like a musical guy yeah
in school and everything and just
different you've been in a lot of
musicals well to see this when i was in
high school you had to go to the theater
to see it you probably could get it on
vhs but that we're going to rent that
rent that we were going to rent you know
it's like a what we would cause it would
be like a real horror movie or something
we had to pay back them
and honestly i still remember
when this movie when rocky horror
picture show first came out on vhs in
the 90s
and i remember going to media play
because i wanted to buy it because i was
very excited that it was coming out
because i'd never seen it outside of a
theater setting yeah that [ __ ] was like
98 98 99 yeah yeah so like on for vhs
yeah and i was just kind of like yep
can't afford that yeah they weren't
playing back then
yeah
that's what i mean well and i kind of
feel like back in the old days that's
why they were so
um they'd get so mad if you like didn't
bring the movies back because they're
like look those are like 300 each you
know what i mean it wasn't like now
where everything's just like [ __ ]
throw away but yeah back then and so i
couldn't afford it so i didn't get it
for a really long time until like the
prices came down and then you know it
came out on dvd and [ __ ] like that and
then i had it then but
um so just recently do you remember like
when was it like a couple years back
you remember when fox was doing uh the
live
[ __ ] and they did grease and that was
great actually we saw that a couple of
times they did rocky horror picture show
as well
and i wanted to see it
um you know it was live on tv and then
they would like reshow it
and uh but i never got around to seeing
it and then like a couple of our friends
thought and set out it wasn't all that
good so i never bothered watching it but
now i'm kind of like curious
to see like how it came out
because
i don't know i mean i kind of feel like
i i wouldn't mind seeing like a modern
staging of this although as i said
the movie you really can't beat tim
curry in that role it's like i really
can't
yes i've seen like a lot of other
you know running that show i mean i've
seen a lot of other people play him like
in live casts and theaters and stuff
over the years
but
i mean he just owns that role so much
and he just owns this i mean everybody
in this movie is great i just love this
whole movie i love all the songs and
everything but
just that one moment when he comes down
the elevator you know what i mean with
the cape and like just like [ __ ]
throws that cape off and [ __ ] it's just
so [ __ ] great what a great
introduction i think tim curry's career
was kind of built on this role
well yeah his performance in this
actually
i think that basically i think this and
clue are my favorite ones of his have
you ever seen clue no oh
yeah he's good in that too but um you
know obviously this one's like super
over the top and he and he's like real
sexy in this one too well like his
facial expressions the way he moves and
everything you know you're dealing with
a really really good performer real good
actor
and just like i mean just he belts those
[ __ ] songs out
and then um they they said that i guess
early on in the production when he was
still doing the stage musical he decided
that he thought for whatever reason that
dr franken further should talk very very
posh he's like he's chocolate he should
talk like the queen of england yeah so
he does like this super super posh like
yes he has an english accent but he like
poshed it up for this so
so for some reason like that really
works like that combo
but
yeah he just [ __ ] owns this like so
much and it's just
i mean it's everything about it is
perfection every little and it just
even like it's very physical performance
which i had forgotten about
and like watching him run around that
castle
in those big glittery high heels
and [ __ ] like that and i was like wow i
had forgotten like how physically
uh taxing this role was and how
just i mean when he's that scene where
he's like chasing rocky like around the
rim where the tank is and he just keeps
like running and like falling down like
shaking his fist at him and all this and
just like it's just a great comedic like
physical performance and i had forgotten
a lot of the aspects of it so it's
really like i said it's really nice to
watch it without all the other stuff
going on even though that's fun but it's
nice to watch it because you can
actually appreciate it as a movie and as
a musical which you can't really do
runs around does all these [ __ ]
action scenes and [ __ ] damn [ __ ]
negligee
in a corset
merry widow with
because i'm a girl and i can't run
around in heels like that so [ __ ] man
and it's just and it's funny too because
at the end when they do the floor show
part where they have like brad and janet
and all that like brad
who he's supposed to be like a square
um so when they put him in the heels and
the fishnets and he's out there dancing
and he's all like kind of flopping
around like a dork but they make that
yeah you know that's what makes it funny
is that he's you know obviously not
uh he's not used to wearing them the way
frank is so he's not like real
comfortable in it but it's just i don't
know i just he's losing her mind i know
what's the matter pogba she knows
there's another flavor there oh she's
like yeah i want to try that one look
look look she's like let me let me try
this one now let me try this one
oh okay knock this [ __ ] down knock it
down she knocked it off knock it down
she looked at me this one
okay open this please i can't open it
but yeah so uh so yeah if you guys have
seen the fox one let me know what that's
like but and also if you guys have been
to
any of the um
if you i saw this in the theater live
well like i did
like i said i think that's kind of cool
that
that was my first introduction to it um
even though i love it as a movie and i
like to just sit and watch it you know
now because i can appreciate all the all
the stuff in it all the songs and
everything but i like that i first got
to
[Applause]
you're so noisy i'm just doing what i
got to do
i like that i first that i first got to
experience it like when i was in high
school
in in that setting and just goes to show
even though this came out way back in
1975
this weekend which uh if you're watching
this at some other time this is
halloween weekend 2021 uh this is going
up on the friday tomorrow night saturday
october 30th
mannequins in downtown sanford is doing
a rocky horror night everyone's supposed
to come dressed like rocky horror
characters they're going to show all the
things so
shit's still going strong nowadays this
many decades later
so
just goes to show so anyway uh have a
happy halloween everybody and uh we will
see you guys on the next one
bye